with all these brothers there because
there's a lot of brothers being let out
of prison
how can we make sure at project hood
that we help in that area and that we
create
opportunities
and create a vehicle for total life
change
[Music]
hello my name is pastor corey brooks and
i'm coming to you from the rooftop on
the south side of chicago where i've
been living in this tent and i plan to
stay there for 100 days from november
the 20th to february 28th talking about
the issues talking about violence
talking about solutions all the things
that impact us every single day on the
south side of chicago i want to thank my
fox family for giving us the platform to
talk about what we call rooftop
revelations and from time to time i get
to bring in guests
to talk about issues that impact us so
today i have on our
rooftop revelations
jeff boyd we calling rafi
he is the man who is responsible
for the re-entry program at project hood
he makes sure that we stop the cycle of
brothers going back and forth to prison
getting out going back getting out going
back
breaking the recidivism that we see
every single day on the south side so
jeff
good to have you on here man yeah thank
you my pleasure
one of the things i want to ask you
about is
um the community center
and
why is it so important that we have this
community center
as it relates to recidivism and reentry
a product of the federal institution for
more than 25 years
state federal and county institutions
they offer classes and re-entry
they offer um
resources
to allow you to reintegrate back in the
community these classes are often inside
an institution but when the door is open
and you're released back to the
community that is quite a different
question we need an institution we need
individuals we need programs we need
project hood on the outside to receive
those individuals leaving the
institution with the services and
resources they need to successfully
reintegrate back into these communities
you know what let me ask you a question
because somebody might be watching this
saying look
what does that have to do with me
reentry recidivism i'm not in prison
never been to prison i'm not going to
prison none of my family is in prison
what is this how does this impact me in
my community
and what do you say about that
what i have to say about that is that
first i'm testament and i'm a living
example that um
that it impacts our communities i cannot
imagine
an individual's coming home without
someone here to receive them to give
them the resources
the services
the tools and the skills they need to
become productive members of these
communities because once they become
productive members of our communities
our communities thrive
and develop
and better the quality of life of
individuals inside our communities
but the opposite what is what happens
when
individuals don't get those resources
when they don't get when individuals get
out of prison and they don't have the
family or they don't have an
organization like project hood to come
alongside and help them
typically
what happens typically what happens is
an individual
return back to the old lifestyle return
back to the street return back to the
way they know to survive out here on the
street without the tools necessary to
survive
so it's critically important that we be
able to receive them and give them the
tools they need to be productive members
of these communities
one last thing
[Music]
how do you think project hood is going
to be able to impact and help this
situation with
with all these brothers because there's
a lot of brothers being let out of
prison
how can we make sure at project hood
that we help in that area and that we
create
opportunities and create a vehicle for
total life change
project hood
offers an array of services for
individuals coming home from
institutions
we direct them to employment we direct
them to certification we divert
direct them to skills and the tools they
need to be successful out here i cannot
imagine willa underneath surrounding
communities being without project entry
project hood re-entry services i just
cannot imagine it
well jeff you know i'm proud of you
thank you for leading our efforts to
make sure that we stop the cycle of
recidivism thank you for leading the
efforts in trying to make sure that we
guide
these young brothers to in the right
direction giving them
opportunities alternatives and options
but most of all thank you for
staying on them not letting them use any
excuse making them take responsibility
so that all of us can be
uh
better and so that we can transform our
neighborhood so i appreciate you and i
thank you thank you for being on the
project good thing it's my pleasure all
right i know that's right
listen it's awesome thank y'all so much
for being with us once again
the rooftop revelations
shout out as always to fox for giving us
this platform and i'll we'll see you on
tomorrow and as i always say
peace
you